spécial retour au travail au menu de ce
petit restaurant asiatique du centre
ville de montréal un retour progressif
selon gérant j'ai
difficile ne lave pas tous les bons et
si maintenant pressé
comme-ci comme-ça ses collègues
apprécient de se voir en personne voit
qu un mandat au bureau audience à ses
coordonnées des fois avec des collègues
ça fait du bien au moral allez prendre
un launch ensemble tant que leurs
employeurs demeurent flexible est ce que
ça vous tenterait de revenir du lundi au
vendredi
je ne pense pas la formule hybride m'a
vraiment permis par exemple si j'ai des
rendez vous quoi que ce soit ou je dois
visiter des clients c'est beaucoup plus
simple la chambre de commerce du
montréal métropolitain effectué depuis
la fin du télétravail obligatoire en jeu
2021 une série de sondages pour prendre
le pouls de retour au bureau
centre-ville parmi les faits saillants
du dernier coup de sonde en juin 2021 28
% des travailleurs étaient de retour au
bureau ils sont maintenant 68 % des
travailleurs à fréquenter leurs bureaux
à temps plein ou à temps partiel
c'est qu'elle était le travail est là
pour rester que le mode hybrid est
apprécié et va s'installer dans les
entreprises par contre on peut dire
qu'on a des résultats qui sont très très
encourageant pour la vitalité central et
ceux qui sont de retour dépenses
pratiquement autant que durant la
période prix pandémie avant la pandémie
les travailleurs dépensait
hebdomadairement en moyen de 111 dollars
puis nos résultats sondages démontrent
qu'ils sont à 106 dollars donc la baisse
des dépenses est un séminaire d
importants employeurs du secteur c'est
hydro québec avec plus de 7000 employés
au coeur de la ville la société d'état
veut analyser cette nouvelle donne dans
les prochains mois
on compte en moyenne trois jours de
télétravail par semaine on sait pas
comment ça va se passer à long terme
donc on se donne plusieurs mois pour
voir comment ça se déroule soit sur le
terrain le bémol reste le transport en
commun le tiers des travailleurs crédit
attrapé le virus pour ce qui est des
journées les plus populaires en présence
les mardi mercredi et jeudi ont la cote
c'est que le centre-ville retrouve sa
vitalité il simule saint-françois radio
canada montréal